so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up marvel lights welcome to
marvel let's play i'm josh late i'm
joined by our brand new marvel let's
play host erica ishii what's up
hi josh thank you so much for like uh
i'm part of the team i'm sorry i just i
don't know just like sorry rattled me
for a second hearing that come out of
your mouth um this is wild uh hi i'm
erica ishii you may know me perhaps from
my work with vegan sundry critical role
um i am a voice actor uh i'm anna bray
in destiny 2 and i am in this game that
we are going to play today marvel's
avengers i am maddie cho and uh you can
hear me
sort of all over the base and i'm also
the
pa at aim
uh which is which is i'm i'm really
looking forward to because i haven't
really gotten to play much of this so it
feels it feels weird but if we what if
we run into mean game i don't know we'll
find out it's gonna be fun
we're playing hot dogs yes yes as all of
that all of that and more i can't wait
to get into this with you so let's i
mean let's just let's just dive right in
awesome
[Music]
all right we are in the game you're
playing as kate bishop i'm playing as
clint barton aka hawkeye for both
hawkeye hawkeye
uh
[ __ ] guy i i mean your video game
background is amazing you you hinted at
it scratched the surface when you were
introducing yourself
it's
amazing i i want to know so much more
about it but let's let's get into future
wastelands uh all this is playable right
now came out march 18th for free if you
own the game you don't have to play the
campaign to play it
but we're gonna do the you in funeral
let's do it
uh also if you have any questions for us
uh about the game about uh our favorite
marvel heroes about my illustrious video
game career i guess uh please ask it in
the chat
yes yes we are live so feel free send us
your love tell us your support any
questions you got i got a question for
you all while we're launching into this
mission who's your favorite marvel hero
you know you told me you were gonna ask
this question i should have taken the
time to think of an answer but i didn't
um it's it's fine i think the the marvel
comics that i read the most growing up
were uh spider-man and i think it was
amazing spider-man actually
uh
yeah it's
spider-man and then i
think
i mean i
i have such a soft spot for an x-men
um when i was little my mom got me one
of those like
you can read books with picture books
and it was jubilee's origin story
because she was really excited that
there was a chinese-american character
that i could look up to uh and you know
since then i i've definitely i've
cosplayed a couple of times as jubilee
and uh
i haven't
played any other marvel characters
i'm not sure i just it's
it it is so it was what's wild to me you
know after growing up reading the comics
and and watching all the cartoons to
have been part of this uh and i didn't
know
what the game was when i got cast in it
um
and originally it was supposed to be
just doing background voices
uh
and so
but like i don't know do you know chris
christopher sean at all i don't think so
no exactly like a very handsome young
man um but he and i were in the walla
group the walla grouper
is the group of sort of voice actors
that provide atmospheric voices and it's
just a blast because you
you just improvise a bunch of
chatter in the background and so
can you give us like what that would
sound like just like a little like
like a teaser
well it was wild because they uh you
know we found out you know sort of in
the space of this five minutes okay uh
this is gonna be marvel's avengers uh
and then you're this first scene is all
and then we started geeking out because
for sean and i were here what we were
doing fans and we were like um
excuse me but you know sort of what uh
characters are canon in the marvel
avengers universe
uh
you know like can we get a list and and
they're like oh yeah actually we'll call
up the developers and get a list of
characters that exist in the marvel
avengers universe and then
we just started freaking out about it um
and then they said okay well you're at a
a fan convention for which is you know
the a day
uh convention and so they're like just
go wild just talk about and you can talk
about any of the characters that are on
this list
uh you can
um
just just be really excited that you're
gonna
maybe see some of the
some of the superheroes like oh we can
do this
also i'm bad at talking while game
or you're going to get a coherent
thought out of me or i'm going to be
good at fighting uh i think we know
which is going to be
right the art of juggling and playing
video games at the same time right yeah
well and i can do it i just won't
necessarily be good at it you know
well uh our report card will be sent to
you in the mail after
i'm being graded oh okay
uh um that's that's amazing i mean oh
man just like the thought of like going
because when you go to those you know
auditions it's like top secret you have
no idea what it's gonna be and then they
tell you and your heart just goes wait
wait i'm sorry what
yeah i was originally supposed to just
do background voices and then they said
hey uh we have a character that we want
you to play like can you uh this
character maddie cho and i was like
amadeus joe's sister and they're like oh
god know her
oh that's amazing i i would i have to
totally agree with you spider-man is my
favorite marvel hero
i i grew up reading spider-man comics
and i just
i have them all over my walls
oh really yeah yeah i mean it's it's
just
to be honest with you i never thought
that it would become cool
you know
it's it's like i mean that that's such
an old person thing to say i guess it's
like back in my day you know we it was
considered very uncool to like
superheroes
um but honestly it's really wonderful to
see
uh
stories that we grew up with uh
touched so many more people's lives now
yes i've been so excited about it
yeah everyone has like a shirt a
backpack some sort of like thing that
they're wearing to show their favorite
hero i love it yeah
like yeah see see i told you there's
gonna be
uh a coherent conversation or i'm gonna
be good um but
uh yeah i mean just just the idea like
hawkeye not that many people necessarily
knew about who who hawkeye was and now
you know he's got his own
he's got his own missions
it's awesome i'm coming i'm coming i'm
coming to rescue you
that's okay
sonic photo nice clint outfit choice
thank you um i am six points away from
unlocking the challenge card to get the
ronin outfit and i can't wait
i think black widow's just gonna like
keep like hanging around you
oh yeah i did thank god
hey thank goodness for ai right
oh man when i played this game the ai is
like we know you're
yeah
okay um
also chat let us throw your favorite
hero too
uh so
yeah yeah
who who do all the kids like these days
for for you spider-man spider-man all
the way i am
a huge spider-man fan yeah like my
friends come over they're like you don't
have any pictures of anything else other
than the spider-man wall i was like i
don't see the problem with that sentence
and they go you're 30. family
around
yeah
family my phone
my family is is peter parker yes oh heck
look how cool i like
kale extremes josh you've gotten clint
proficient i like it thank you thank you
uh
kate clint and nat says it's
sasha saying the names on on twitch is
the hardest thing to do
uh revealing too much daredevil for sure
oh daredevil love david oh
[Applause]
so i think one of the earliest comics
that i remember reading
of the wider mcu
that
i
that really stuck with me was marvel
1602. did you ever read that one i don't
think so
by neil gaiman uh which is because i'm a
huge neil gaiman who also did the
eternal series as well
right and
and uh
and i love that era of history you know
i'm like a big shakespeare geek
um oh i'm not jumping oh oops sorry i
gotta figure out a jump
and talk
uh and so so i read that and it's really
beautiful you know sort of the pencil
that includes even just the pencil
sketches are just gorgeous and um
there's i think there's even some like
silver engraving style covers just to
replicate this you know the style of the
period and
it's just it's just really beautiful and
really interesting and really
interesting take because it's you know
sort of an alternate universe in which
um they all exist in elizabethan england
so
oh was that the one is that the one
where spider-man like has like that
white uh thing around his neck and he's
like back back in the day like
shakespearean times i think oh like the
the elizabethan rough does it i it's
like
it's uh
i think it's dr strange this is a while
ago but doctor strange was is like the
advisor to queen elizabeth
and uh
yeah yeah he's her like magic advisor i
think and then um
oh man i think the reason i brought this
was because daredevil's really awesome
because you know in
our comics he's he's you know an
irish-american sort of icon and in this
he's sort of just like a he's like a
full-on irish and i think he's got the
accent written out and everything
that's awesome yeah and uh
yeah and dr doom is in it and i think
it's it's
yeah it's just i don't know it's all the
things that i really like
dr doom is one of the most like baddest
villains in marvel in my opinion i yeah
i i look forward to seeing him
appear more i guess in
[Music]
in in the world just in general in
comics movies
in games oh
man
he was in that was not a tease by the
way by the way i have zero knowledge of
anything that's that is coming up
in any of this so uh i cannot
accidentally give anything away which is
the best way for me to do you entrusted
us with nothing
yes
yeah
uh caleb streams in game i mean widow
and kate but in the general universe
agent coulson i'm not even sorry yes
i love coulson
and
there's something always really great
about the human
characters if you will yeah
because they're surrounded by all these
like super heroed you know humans that's
like all right how like what are they
gonna do in the situation where they
can't rely on any powers right yeah
and and it you know they're sort of the
they're sort of the audience throwing it
because like for real if i exist in the
nc in the marvel universe
you know i
don't know if i'd be born with mutant
powers i don't know if i
you know i don't have the money to to be
a tony stark nor the
engineering genius
what if i'd be a colson you know if
that's an honorable noble thing to be
100 a shield agent absolutely
oh no i'd be nick fury i'd be like a
nick fury i have character that's sorry
that's it
i realized
oh no
real
superpowers i'm sorry i'm i'm just
looting i'm being a loot goblin back in
the cave here i love looting and i
always get everyone every time i play
with friends like can you stop looting
and play with us sorry yeah never
apologize for looting whatever
you're
that's right we had a moment we had like
a moment of connection before the stream
here where are we
here
okay
oh yeah people make fun of me for being
a lewd goblin and i was like
that's what they call me
okay cool i got never miss i got one
more
one more and i have to vault i do combo
four hits after vault i'm coming oh
ronin i'm coming for you coming for you
ronin i'm coming for you i'm coming for
you okay
i think
i so my
knowledge of example
hawkeye
uh comes from probably and again
my memory is terrible
right now
and i can only concentrate on
word or or fight
um
but
uh the matt fraction
run
right is so again the art is amazing and
it's
uh
so
it's a great update to him
it's it's amazing it was actually one of
the first hawkeye comics i read like
i want to say like a couple years ago
yeah
i didn't know a lot about hawkeye uh
spiderman was like my main wheelhouse
and i'm like wait let me read up on him
yeah
okay
so we have to
acquire the great combat schematics all
right
okay so if you had to choose a
character any villain or hero to play
video games
oh yeah i know
um
[Music]
just probably at xavier's school
you choose a location too i like that
you know the the
the holo room
um where you can
just do full on
like are yeah it's just full on ar
um ar vr oh my god
well with as many people as you wanted
um
and like anybody could come by you know
just just anybody
i feel like
yeah i feel like i mean spiderman would
obviously enjoy it
you know he's a fun kid
um
i feel like
uh
um yeah i mean just just just as long as
i had the tech for it
that makes it really funny would be a
sore
winner uh for for games if it was if it
was pvp
he wouldn't he wouldn't let us would it
be like right yeah yeah
he would have jarvis like hack the
system yeah exactly so i don't think you
can handle losing
uh how about you how about you who's
your pick
to play video games
uh hey oh it's char says cater clint
would be great to play with yeah chat
let us know who would you want to play
video games with
yeah
there's a chest with games i mean is it
weird i mean i don't think i would
actually choose this but just for the
comedy sake is it weird that i would
choose doctor doom
uh no no that's that'd be fun
he's just getting angry throwing the
controller against the wall
yeah
uh
[Applause]
i don't know i bet they had some great
games in love area
oh yeah right all all doom propaganda
games yeah it is it's just all he's like
the main character in all the games and
okay
all right i'm here secure the area
during the
data oh do you say data or data because
that is something that definitely comes
up in most video games that i do voices
i see data
one data okay do you say data it depends
but then sometimes if i think too hard
about it i might say data
oh that's okay i i didn't yeah i
activated i'll be fine i got i got some
of the team with me thank you thank
goodness for uh
good old matt
she's got my back
dad i guess it depends on the sentence
right it depends
computer data computer data
computer data i'd probably say data i
can see any of them
oh tons of uh kale extremes groot i like
to play games with groot okay but
teenagers
no baby groot baby well i do love adult
fruit too but remember you're training i
oh man
like adult crew would be chill and fun
to play with
but
uh baby group would just be so cute he's
so cute
there's so much loot over there but i'm
gonna go help you
no it's okay i'm coming i can come to
you
oh man yeah
ah cool
oh even if i lose or even if i uh
oh i mean you're here so now they can
see but like even if i i made a terrible
mess of things i'd be
sort of
on my own so
you can't you couldn't necessarily see
oh yeah right because your screen's not
being shown
oh you lucky
i can just kind of have fun and mess
around
get revived by nat all the time
uh oh
yeah
there we go
yeah
take that
nice
yes i love these finishers
oh yeah the finishers are so awesome
feels very satisfying
they are
they are not stopping all right all
right yeah
um
okay
all right oh
what was that
oh the firestorm
yeah that is definitely
no boy now um
okay got some help
okay where are you at
oh there you are i'll tell you over
there okay i gotta stay near you this
time so we can like
actually play as hot guys
so good we could like team up there we
go yeah
all right
yeah t-ball
okay that's pretty good
yeah because i
oh yeah all right all right all right
okay we're back at it we're back at it
you got this oh it's shiny
all right
so
that all loaded up yeah
so this game has like tons of marvel
characters you can play as do you have
like uh
like a go to maine that you have
i haven't gotten to play this before
i am really
so weirdly enough
i almost feel like
i played more games before i was
voicing them
because it's weird i am very
self-critical of my performances uh it's
difficult for me to listen to it but you
know it's funny because i if
i
wasn't in this i probably would have
played a lot
a lot
but
i don't know so this is actually a
really good excuse for me to
play it with you i feel that because
when i was an actor i couldn't like i
couldn't ever watch my like own shows or
films
and
once heard that you know as an artist
it's hard to look at your own work
because by the time you finish it you've
learned so much from the periods of
doing it that you know it just feels
like old stuff yeah already
um yeah that and you know we are we are
very self-critical people but there's a
chest up here by the way
fellow loot goblin
yes oh
[Music]
uh i finally feel like i'm being seen
that's right you are so valid you are so
bad well you have all the best tech and
you can get the cool skins you know it's
just it's just then then who's the
goblin
outfit
like oh man i cannot wait they they just
unveiled a new iron man outfit i think
last week that's in the marketplace and
oh it's beautiful it's the white one
with the with the visor
all right wow
okay yeah i'm kind of at a distance and
just
gonna i'm gonna take him out from
they get it
oh there's a there's a chest over here
we see orbs ooh
ooh could you imagine that you're like
fighting with avengers and like wait
wait wait let's get some loot yes i'm
100 i can imagine that
i feel like maybe that would be maybe
that would be our superpowers in the
marvel universe maybe we would be
the tech person you know that we've got
this like bag of holding
where it's just got everything in it and
we're like oh hang on let me there's a
dumpster right here we gotta
do a dive real quick
oh man there'd be like a bag like a
never ending bag
let me just show you my loot
yeah you'd have to bring that person
with you everywhere exactly
we're like we're like the soccer mom of
the avengers yeah
all right everybody have your orange
slices anybody do orange slices anybody
hand sanitizer hand sanitizer time yeah
either
there's just like there's just like all
this like alien goop on like on the
avengers just like you need to hand
sanitize you go
like yeah i have just the thing for this
this is the least of my concerns
all right
oh that's so funny reach the twin jet
landing zone
all right uh-oh oh you're already there
oh man i was looting okay
sorry you're doing the right thing i'm
looting i thought well i was going
towards where i thought luke might be
but
i was i was mistaken
all right there we go
oh there's the quinchin
yeah
all right okay oh no
oh no
natalie
i'm coming i'm coming
i know i'm not nat but you know second
best thing
all right
well she did it
whoa i'm invisible what oh yeah nats
ability allows uh anybody in the area to
be invisible when they do the ability
it's awesome oh whoa and you can buff it
so every time whoever becomes invisible
gets more critical damage no
so you're telling me that i should be
strategizing with my team instead of
running off and
just kind of
smashy smashy
i mean yeah i mean but there's no wrong
way to play
it's true that's true
all right
yeah if you hold circle okay you can
fall
[Music]
oh no
thanks cap
three four five
i did it yes
okay where are you at i know there's a
fight happening right now we're putting
it on rodent
yes
[Applause]
oh nice
let me see it let me see let me see
whoa
that does look cool
challenge card completed
all right all right we're almost we got
we got this
old scorpion buddy
dread bot excuse me
i don't know
the weak points of these are the
red vents
yeah
nice all right
oh we got chats and we're going to get
that rodent see now i'm shouting yes
thank you chad
brad congrats i'm so happy i was like
i'm going to try and time this to go
live i'm gonna unveil
oh my gosh my very first mission
that's awesome way to go
do you wanna do you wanna try hawkeye or
clint
uh yeah
i'll do that i like i love i love i love
being kate bishop
but uh yeah sure some hot guy
so that was the future wastelands
mission the you in funeral
that you can play within uh this
campaign for future imperfect
and now we're going to go ahead and
switch up characters and get into
another mission and we're teaming up as
kate and clint
all right select heroes cool i'll go
into cab so you can switch out to
hawkeye
thank you and there you go there's kate
for you uh played by ashley burch who
yes
yes
she sounds like everybody in this is
crushed i crushed it
uh cool all right let's do another
mission in the war too let's get in here
let's see where the snowy tundra at
there we
[Music]
let's do a drop zone drop zones are
super quick well depending on how long
you want to do it like five ten minutes
which is great to be like go in do some
challenges level up uh or even find some
loot too for these uh drop zones
i like to do drop zones it's like oh
cool i got work in like 15 minutes let
me do a job
yeah
just like just to just okay we got time
we got time we got time there's always
time it's always time
it's fine
uh so while we're loading in let me
explain the challenge card for what
basically what i did with uh clint each
character comes with a challenge card
the first four characters in the game um
when you get them uh are available
actually the first let's see who is it
it's
hulk thor iron man cap black widow
are all
included with the challenge card and
kamala and kamala khan all included with
their challenge
so you don't have to
get you
and
uh for both of the hawkeyes you can use
the coins you got from doing the
challenge cards and the other characters
um that came free included to unlock the
challenge card so every time you do
these weekly or daily missions which
i'll show you a little bit
um you unlock new outfits new coins new
uh new
uh materials
temporarily here we go
i'm only on level six with kate kate is
the only challenge card i have not
completed yet i've completed everyone's
except for kate
wow
um but so there's 40 levels that you can
do and you need 200 points to get them
and so level 40 is usually the legendary
outfit
which would be this one
so my weeklies are defeat 25 enemies
without being downed
open dna strong boxes in the vault
so i don't have a lot of volt missions
available right now so i'm going to
refresh that i get one refresh so i'm
going to go and refresh that and now
it's complete villain sectors
dailies complete hives and hit three
more enemies with a single explosion
arrow i'm going to go ahead and refresh
the hive one
nice oh
nice
yo what's up hawkeye
okay
all right
yeah i'm just kind of just kind of
experimenting for the moment yeah yeah
things are going the main difference
between clint and kate is clint doesn't
teleport like kate does
this
good mobility
with the grapple
yeah the grapple arrow it's r2 and
triangle if you're playing on
playstation uh it's awesome because you
go straight directly to the enemies
oh there's a there's a chest up here
oh oh we got to do that
we got it
[Music]
i need access to multiple terminals
the more the better okay access to
terminal so we got to go to these
locations and stay on them
um before they hack that get them hacked
so i'll go to bed
[Music]
is what you want ooh like if i was like
if i was a hero
if you were a hero
okay well okay what would you want and
what would you think it is
you know like in in real life you know
like okay i would say the ability to
fix or break things with my mind
what yeah like anything anything so for
example
or just if someone came up to me with
like a broken heart i'd be able to bend
it
for example if there was a villain that
was a bad villain and i needed to like
break their mind or you know something i
could do that with like my mind
to like incapacitate them so they don't
do any bad things
right okay wow that seems kind of op it
would be totally okay
but yeah that's great that's great um so
i guess technically that would be matter
manipulation no because like because it
works for feelings too yeah
i mean is it possible no but
no i mean well we're talking about super
powers here but i mean
anything broken any physical things like
let's say my blender broke boom
my car is broken
oh man that that would be
that'd be great um
that's good okay so but what what and
then what is your answer of what you
think it would be
like what is your what would your oh
like like what would like the actual
power oh man
yeah
manipulation of
atoms i don't know of cells manipulation
of cells and atoms
that that's what you think you would
have
oh you mean oh you mean in real life
oh oh i think that what would be the
name of that power oh okay oh man in
real life my power probably finding a
good deal
i would probably say that
actually i'm good at fighting deals
again you know that's great great
support hero
i'm such a supporter
when i was younger i always said i
wanted
mind control powers right because you
know i don't need telekinesis if i can
just tell you to go
pick something up for me right
but like it's probably you can't have
mind control and not be evil because
it's inherently you know sort of
invasive right
um
so i feel like
like that's probably the evil answer but
that would be the most useful
yeah it's basically the purple man to
jessica jones right exactly which is
like you can't you know if you have that
power how could you accidentally i mean
or
how could you not use it right
or how would you ever use it in a very
ethical way in a good way
so that but i think in real life my and
my power would be
i mean it's like we're talking mundane
superpowers
um
it probably is still getting along with
with almost anybody
uh or just like chameleon powers i guess
um and then
you know if it were something about me
that's sort of here's what i need
ratcheted up a notch it would be
[Music]
um
energy probably like concussive energy
blasts because i've got a lot of
welcome back okay
that's cool so right now i'm getting
villain sectors we just finished the
drop zone so uh every day this refreshes
at 1 pm eastern time
you can grab the shield faction and the
inhuman faction
kind of missions if you will or extra uh
stuff so you can get more materials and
upgrade your factions so i just
basically got the villain sectors
uh so let's see where they'll show it to
us so we could do a villain sector oh
that'd be cool
let's see here
oh no cool do you want to face off
against uh abomination or taskmaster
oh
i think task master let's do it it's
like wait yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
let's do it all right there he is oh uh
revealing too much uh
this is josh the fixer can you find
maddie cho in the ant hill oh we could
totally do are you okay with that
yeah now let's do it let's do it let's
do it if we have time yeah let's do it
yeah yeah yeah let's do it
oh my gosh because i i've gotten to hear
it i had a friend who's like playing a
lot of it and um
he he sent me the clip
that i first got to post when i
announced that i was maddie
uh and it it's wild
it's wild because you know i'm talking
to
kamala
and uh
man
oh uh not all strike team members have
unlocked this mission oh oh oh you
should be are you able to read it up you
should be okay right or no
oh yeah
perfect nice why did you tell me that uh
because you could also go to the faction
to to grab it yourself so that you get
the benefits of it as well
right right we believe scientist supreme
has so sweet so after this villain
sector uh we'll produce we'll end with
uh maddie
uh here we go hoarder gamer kate is
crazy fun to play and her travel
mechanism is great yes
but i'm such a support character i love
every time i play video game i'll choose
like a healer or someone that can like
help my team
increase their damage or something
like a range holder
sort of loot gobliny type characters
like you know
that that can gather items or tower
locks down with an elite guard
oh what
what can i
swap out i wonder
okay i want my ranged rating to go
higher
because she is a ranged character
oh 32 heroic but it drops my range 16
i am upgrading some stuff yeah me too me
too
parker projection arrow hands those are
pretty good that's pretty cool
um
ooh my defense gear
oh
oh i'm playing on somebody else's
account now though
and they'll feel about me
about me all their work
doing the stuff that i like
yeah you know what hey
heck i'm just gonna do it i'm gonna do
what i like about it um
while you're in there let me show this
guy hi my friends darren de paul who is
amazing
just love wow
the skill tree skulltrion
for the ranged stuff is like built
yeah
so you're able to upgrade primary
specialty mastery i think you have to be
a certain level to get into mastery you
think level 10 or higher maybe not maybe
yeah
okay
all right
let's do that okay i'm gonna come to you
coming to you
all right i'm waiting for you in front
of uh the aim labs
yeah
oh oh oh i'm coming kate
there you are um
thank
oh no
there we go all right bunch of enemies
are going to be here
let's go
okay
okay
okay um
oh maybe not maybe they're too scared
yeah you better run
okay
i really do love the the bow animations
and the in the drawing it's really
really great all right let me let me
restart this checkpoint really fast
because they're too afraid to come at us
it's all right we're intimidating we're
very intimidating
yeah
with my with my deal with my deal
finding
[Laughter]
them before you can enter the facility
all right
so if you were beautiful so if you were
to team up with someone in the marvel
universe
who would you choose to team up with
okay it depends on the circumstance
uh because i feel like
uh
you know
uh
somebody like riri or tony stark
would have would be able to provide me
who has no superpowers with tech right
but if you know i need somebody
like captain marvel who who would
actually like just be able to completely
protect me that'd be cool but i'd
probably want my own tech so i'd want
somebody who can get me you know an iron
man suit or something of that nature
right
oh man having your own iron man suit
would be insane
yeah
[Music]
i mean i really like
i'm probably like black and gold is like
black and rose gold is what i've been
rocking as a palette lately for for
you know as much as i can
uh so i feel like that would be what i
would want my oops i totally let that
guy roll over me
but always
thank you
agent
i so yeah i i feel like
um
oh no
sorry
let's see um
uh yeah so it's my iron man suit uh
black and rose gold i
do what i want i i was the ai voice
i mean probably that he's great but uh
you know jarvis is great but
who
would i want i feel like christopher
walken or somebody
really a very particular voice
hello i have a fever
[Laughter]
guys we gotta get back
what's going on over here wow why are we
fighting
oh man
wow
look at the guns on that one why can't
we be friends
exactly
come on it would be so great this is so
funny
uh metal shocker 48 thor's my main
character yes thor oh hulk is down we
got you hulk
i got it
hold you down you need to come back oh
my man don't be afraid you're korean
you're a green guy
we got you
i'm all gonna listen to the stream after
this i'm gonna be like that was a
terrible christmas
what was i thinking i mean look okay i
never listed that one in my resume
uh everybody everybody has a christian
walking impression
or i i i my mine is arnold
schwarzenegger oh no yeah everybody's
gotten arnold
i remember they were talking to
uh
people for some make one some nixon
movie and every sort of staffer that
they talk to always did the impression
it's like cat or elvis or there's just
some people that you can't not do an
impression of
oh mighty quake charm
don't mind if i do
oh i'm gonna do the thing should i show
you the thing what's the thing
um
oh the yeah the computer yeah absolutely
elevator yeah
oh wow
real fancy elevator i know right aim
they got the money
i guess i'll do my emote why not while
we're in here
what's up
oh that's great i love the hulk always
just carries a rock with them
his buddy
i mean if i could just carry a rock with
me at all times first maneuvers i would
whoa
what is that
so there's these gonna be these uh
these uh plates on the bottom there's
four of them i just hit one to open this
the one over here
uh
directly across
oh
um
oh you have to hit it okay yes loot
ah
i see
all right
um
oh these are spooky boys
spooky robot boys so how'd you how did
you get into voice acting
you know i
it's funny because i i grew up doing on
camera acting and a lot of theater and
uh i was at the strasbourg institute uh
method school
and
um
he did a lot of improv
i always loved
uh cartoons and video games growing up
but i didn't think but it's a very
separate skill that on camera or stage
acting and i knew it was sort of a big
buy-in uh but after i
you know at some point i just went screw
it i i want to do this i want to
specifically be in voice acting for
video games that's awesome because i
find it really thrilling that we have
a
new exciting storytelling medium in our
lifetimes and i wanted to be part of
that
and and so yeah so i targeted
specifically video games
that's awesome oh
yeah
my heroics ready oh here we go there's
the xo
let's do it
coming
man the aim
headquarters though is oh there they are
uh definitely my aesthetic though
yeah right here is that wait wait what
are you saying what are you saying here
who's that you want huh
i mean aesthetically
you gotta do it i like what they did
with the places like the corridors the
floating creepy robots
all right i got style what can i say i'm
gonna get back into the quinceanera to
be like where did erica go oh she's just
gonna move into the aim
come on
look at all this track lighting
look at all this
that's that's how they get you that's
how they get you
i am i am very very easily persuaded uh
oh all right okay he'll stop me
okay
let's go exo
yeah
oh okay
defeated we make a good team
we do we do
we we get our loot which is the most
important thing
we all can agree on what is most
important
ooh
new gear
uh that bro says eva layer what what an
aesthetic
seriously if i could just have a
like a beautiful
uh
mid-century modern looking
minimalist uh headquarters on top of an
inactive volcano that
[Music]
i'm already building the pinterest board
could you imagine okay but if like
heroes and villains existed in our world
like super powered people
and that they had they had like etsy's
and pinterest for their for their layers
come on like you know i'm sure there's
been mtv cribs like okay well this is
where the nuclear warheads are built and
you know uh yeah where is the break room
for the henchmen
uh orange people hench people no ham
sandwiches today i just put it into a
request on hr five days ago
all right number 58 we get it
this is the
and this is the wardrobe you know
everybody everybody's got
oh no that was fast oh did you already
wow your test passes
uh yeah
this is where all of the
henching uniforms are
every week we clock in and
we
get to our locker and get ready for a
day of villainy
get ready for a day ability my shift is
nine to five
uh nine am i started at a bank then uh
you know we work our way down to try and
like cause some havoc at the parking
garage yeah we actually got a
surprisingly good uh dental package
with our health insurance policy
i wonder if tony stark pays for the
dental insurance and how the turrets are
the heroes
i mean if he didn't that would be kind
of a jerky move right it's like
oh yeah
let's see
i need i don't know i'm good on health
actually
ah
why why
okay
okay
all right i'm coming
there we go perfect
finisher
nice
oh i'm suppressed i can't i can't dodge
i can't yeah i wasn't able to do mine
either
okay esports hero i prefer an underwater
base or an abandoned castle oh
underwater i do love an underwater base
but that is like we all know that's a
recipe for disaster recipe
um i i mean like if there's okay
uh active volcano uh
volcano because that way you can plan
for
things you know and it can be
magma powered
uh and preferably on some sort of
tropical island i guess what i'm trying
to say is i would like syndrome from the
incredibles is like his uh his
base you know his volcano on their base
probably what i what i want
that would be that would be cool that's
it i i would i mean i would choose i
would choose an island
somewhere far away
you know don't have to worry about
people if i'm a villain probably the
last thing i want is to be around people
yeah and if you're in or maybe like oh
maybe if it is just completely
uh like a
oil rig base so you can be in
international water
i mean as a supervillain i guess sort of
extradition and
uh you know international laws would be
the least you're concerned but
still
because there are certain perks
all right taskmaster you were going down
that's uh
pretty cool
dude don't follow me stop following me
with your shield yeah
all right
oh he's literally coming yeah
okay
all right
ah
this guy
oh my heroic is ready
oh do it do it do it oh no i'm provided
get me back give me a cup all right
here we go all right who's going he's
going down where
he's invisible
yeah he's right there
welders
oh he's invisible
he's on his last like two percent of
health there he is
[Applause]
complete
erica that was so much fun we
did
so well
oh my goodness thank you so much to
everybody for joining me on my very
first run
on the marvel let's play channel and
thank you so much to you josh this was
such a blast i can't believe that we
actually we've been doing this for an
hour that time just flew by
it went so fast i had so much fun like
playing with you getting to know you
more i'm so excited to see more of you
and working more with you as we continue
i'm i'm i'm so excited and just you're a
fan of games and marvel and that just
makes me so excited
and again it's really really wonderful
that we can just
do what we love and be be happy and open
about what we love and thank you so much
everybody else for all your input for
all your questions uh operation hawkeye
future and perfect is available
everywhere today free for all players
all right everybody thank you so much
for watching
and this is marvel
uh
sorry
i didn't get an assassinate with the
euro universe
you